[Music]
is this Clark this interstellar coming
don't see Clark
oh maybe still sleeping dad fragments
are now expected to enter our atmosphere
that's right now know why they say more
of the same where are you going I don't
know home first chance is about to hit
it's only part of it it's going oh [ __ ]
what you look at that hey where's the
explosion
we now are getting word that the
fragment has gets Central Florida wait
are some more pieces gonna hit come on
let's go
two days they got it all wrong there's a
ton of fragment planet-killers space
agencies are predicting an
extinction-level events or maybe
together alright good you just try to
get to safety they've been tracking the
military flights to bunkers in Greenland
it's our only chance
[Music]
[Music]
we'll find you it's okay fourth largest
fragment will hit in less than 24 hours
I swear I'm gonna get my father in a
bunker I know you will sir if you are
hearing this broadcast seek shelter
immediately what is it what's wrong
[Music]
shelter immediately seek shelter
immediately
[Music]